if you see one of these jalapenos that's
grilled that camera right there estilo
latino mexicano that's right this isn't
just something that they put in there as
garnish
that looks good it's the best
yeah look at that
you got to like roast that over actual
fire you got to roast it i can't mess
around on that that's not a microwave
pepper and
most people have never seen this
or seen one like this
uh but
when you order the george lopez you're
going to get
something that you'll see for the first
time
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
lopez george lopez oh my god omg omg hi
oh my god
if you're feeling number one lately
you're not alone start feeling better
with single message
talk space online therapy matches you
with a licensed therapist from the
comfort of your device i think everybody
needs a little help so you can get 100
off your first month with the code omghi
at
talkspace.com do yourself a favor and
get better mentally
contact space
everybody needs help
[Music]
my daughter had two horses and somebody
said to me
that's what you need they said a couple
of things that's when you're making too
much money they said to me don't ever
own anything that shits
or eats while you're sleeping
because it's got to just be fed it's got
to be cleaned and
unless you have a horse guy right and
then the horse guy counts and then the
[ __ ] barn then you got a trainer
loretta lynn's guy
who used to run her ranch he just died
with all the floods in tennessee
he just went down for the count flooding
got him washed away all the [ __ ]
that he went saw and drugs that he did
he gets washed out with a water
like a dude
why can't i go out like
he did loretta lynn but loretta
brooklyn's now not still living
i don't want them to [ __ ] i don't
know i don't i don't know it's not quite
my demographic
that's what you know that's when you
know you've been around too long george
lloyd jordan's still alive i thought
another right away wait a second let me
check 89 years and kick and there you go
you're still great
you know glenn campbell had uh
alzheimer's and then yeah
i'm just kidding you know or tony
bennett yeah his doctors you know
ordered him not to
not the tour anymore because you don't
want can't be out there i left my heart
where the [ __ ] did i leave
[Laughter]
see frankie valley is still singing and
touring
man that's
really yeah they had him on the news
this morning and okay so um
alex cantor i think he's like
you know yes if you're a fan of gangster
movies this is a made man because to me
i say i say this about cantors i say
this about a delicatessen versus
firehouse subs or subway or jersey mics
or you know you want to go pray at a
chapel
or do you want to go to the vatican
a deli like cantor's and your family how
long has it been in there alex 90 years
now 90 years is
at first of all it's not easy to
run a business nine years much less 90
but when you grow up like we grew up
where you go to carnecerias you went to
butcher shops butcher shops were famous
with a better
cut
better
fresher and then all of a sudden now we
started to want
fast food and we started to want
food that from a window where they hand
it to you
just a number
but
people who really know know that a deli
a delicatessen a place you go is not
only a place where
it's family it's
comfort it's you know what you if you
like it you know what's there and then
employees
never leave you still have somebody
there that was there before in the open
we have two employees who have been
there for over 50 years that's what i'm
saying they just had uh the news media
just that when they opened back up again
they did a special
all the all the
employees
never left them
came back to work without hesitation how
they were so excited about getting their
clients back in
just because it's all family oriented
and of course the food is excellent so
if you could get a little bit of that at
your house which is what which is what
people are doing now with you know uh
doordash grubhub sign me up um
uh lopez tacos what are we what are we
doing next bite yeah yeah so well first
of all coming from cantors like it's it
is as you describe this old school place
it's stuck in time it's been around for
90 years my grandfather grew up working
there my dad dropped you know really
dropped everything he did and has worked
there his entire life
and
canners is this uh it's this old school
place but it's it's
actually one of the most popular
restaurants in all of la on postmates
and on these platforms because people
love it uh mozza ball soup is selling
like like crazy right now and um it's
because consumer behavior has changed
people used to get in their car and go
drive to restaurants or you know go go
with their families and now you can open
up an app click one button and food
comes to you and that that convenience
is not a trend and so what we're doing
is uh we're making it
really easy for restaurants to connect
to these customers online and we're
building brands that that are only exist
online like george lopez tacos where
where we're now selling your tacos in
all across the u.s and 35 states and the
quality of it is what you would expect
to get if you went to one of the
restaurants right the the the
explain the process that the meat is the
meat and the the style is a style right
yeah yeah so you know first of all if
the food isn't excellent then what's the
point right you might be able to get
someone to try it once for the first
time but if they're not coming back
you're not building a long-term
sustainable brand you're not building
lifetime value we want to create
experiences that are memorable that you
want to tell your friends about and so
the food is everything you know when we
when we build these brands we're we're
thinking about the best and quality best
quality ingredients that we can source
we're partnering with restaurants to
like teach them really how to make
authentic carnitas and so they so they
teach the the cook the chef how to make
it the way that it's made
in the restaurant
you know so like if you wanted let's say
thrifty's ice cream
the strawberry one with a little piece
of the real strawberry the bastard you
don't find anywhere and somehow
you know it's not as popular as it
should be and and to keep a business
open 90 years but also
to be astute enough to take it to the
next level where now
if you can't
if you're not in l.a i know somebody
that lives in sacramento and they send
me pictures of the churros and the
and the tacos and they got them in
sacramento and they loved it the woman
and their mom got them so you can get
them anywhere you live but also like you
said like you ever see somebody that
that that
you know they look like have big deaths
and then you know you realize
you know
everything else is big too so so first
impressions like
i haven't been in the restaurant
business 90 years my family hasn't but
the place that i grew up going to in san
fernando has been there for maybe 70 70
years but i would say that now because
people in the restrictions and
everything that they like to eat forget
throw that out the window when you
present a
a piece of uh a dish or something
i think you only get one bite like the
bite is is a bigger first impression
than if you see somebody with your eyes
because of your taste and i think you
only get those telling these guys i
think you only get one
that's the first bite is is the most
important and that decides whether
people come back and speak of the devils
we have tacos coming into the studio
right now oh my gosh i hope you're
hungry um how far back does uh where did
where did the re how did your
grandfather started i mean what was that
yeah it was it was my great grandfather
actually yeah 1931 is when we opened in
boyle heights um which is was where
there were a lot of jewish people in
that neighborhood now it's very hispanic
but
um we migrated over to fairfax avenue
which is where
the whole jewish hub of la was in the
50s and we've been there ever since and
the street has you know changed
substantially there used to be 15 jewish
delis just on fairfax avenue in the 50s
or the only one left so
you know we've we've survived all these
years by innovating by thinking about
you know what's next how are people
interacting with restaurants how do we
need to adapt and change and even though
we're an old school restaurant
we still
are updating the menu constantly we now
have a vegan reuben we've got vegetarian
matzo ball soup on the menu and people
are coming in and they're getting locks
with a with a gluten-free bagel because
that's that's what people are into at
the time yeah so i think we've gotten
this far by really embracing this
mentality of adapt or die and
every year we're questioning what
technology should we be embracing to to
carry this business forward and what
changes do we need to make to to stay on
our toes obviously keeping it authentic
and old school though
where did um
what is it where did gluten come from
what i mean
is it the white person's
i have no one i think it's the white
person
but that was why i don't know if it's
around
up until about five years ago i had
never heard of gluten
so gluten is do you think it's in the
way that
you start to process the wheat
or the or whatever you make bread with
maybe a chemical or maybe as
a manufactured seed that's not organic
well i i think people are are realizing
like certain foods you know affect them
in different ways yeah definitely
apologize
napkins or something yeah i think
they're bringing some in but if you're
not let me go double check mexican are
you still i gotta get started
no but one of the things that you
mentioned earlier um
you said your friend texted you from in
sacramento he was able to order these
tacos we're very lucky we grew up in
california where there's amazing tacos
everywhere on every corner but if you go
to some of the suburbs of uh you know
albuquerque new mexico or um
indianapolis you don't have authentic
mexico city style tacos and like for us
to bring this brand to life and and
partner with restaurants all over mom
and pop restaurants small you know small
and medium businesses and teach them how
to make this this authentic food it's
bringing this flavor and these these
recipes to places that don't have that
exposure how do we get people to go back
to like
a deli where
you know
fourth street deli in new york or the
carnegie closed i love the carnegie
closed yeah you know there's there's not
the deli culture is a really it's a
dying breed right now because
it is right at one point there were 3
000 jewish delhi's in america obviously
you got all your delis in new york and
miami and major cities but
today there's actually less than 150
jewish delis left in the u.s
and every week it feels like there's
more and more closing green blacks just
closed last week i know man that was a
sad one for us yeah i mean dude that
that's
that's that was that was some real
matcha ball soup up there
like and you know
we're all part of this i mean when that
it's when those places go
a little bit of of what makes us
comfortable oh thank you goes too you
know and that and that's the thing that
we should always have things that are
comfortable to us that
you know
if you're sick you know we go to cancers
we get matzo ball soup and you go to
greenblatt you get soup and then that's
gone and now you're going to
i don't know uh somewhere in getting
soup it's not the same
panera panera
it's you know it was last year was a
devastating year for restaurants a
hundred and twenty thousand businesses
shut their doors down it's a lot of
people working
and you know at canners we had 150
full-time employees before coven
and when they had to close down our
dining room we had to send people home
waiters bus boys dishwashers that have
been there 30 40 50 years and and
that was that was really a devastating
moment for us for for the restaurant for
my family um we told everyone come in
and and you know eat eat with us have
lunch on us like
um while you know while we work through
this and this is a you know fluid
situation that we got to navigate but we
were so happy to be able to bring people
back
and what we're doing with nexbite
um by partnering with restaurants and
bringing more orders into their kitchen
we're increasing the the chances that
they're going to survive this and and
make it out on the other side even
stronger with a more profitable and
sustainable model which is really what
this is all about is how do we build
brands and and and bring to life more
orders that can be going through these
kitchens that are so underutilized if
you think about a restaurant as like a
manufacturing facility of food they're
operating at 30 output maybe you know
there's dinner rush or certain times of
the day where they're busy but for all
the other times they're kind of slow so
we can we can come in
turn on these these extra brands for
them and light them up with an extra 5
10 20 30 online orders a day and you can
be outside of indianapolis and have
tacos from los angeles it's
that
tastes like they're from los angeles and
don't taste like it's an interpretation
of some place wow
that just has a name you know of of a
restaurant but it's not
you know doesn't it doesn't go beyond
the latino name you know i'll i'll be
honest with you
in the documentary that we thank god
finally it says
you know i was
i was laughing because we went to an
italian restaurant little joe's in
chinatown
yeah and i was laughing because
here i was sitting there
i didn't know what the hell i was
ordering the first time i've been in an
italian restaurant and i mean i was
already at homicide bureau it was a
homicide bureau so i'm already in my
early 30s it's the first time i ever
went into a
into canters the first time i'd gone
into a jewish deli amazing it was uh and
now i i go back
i just uh
it's wonderful
i don't know if anybody's ever had matzo
ball soup i don't even know if most
chicanos most latinos even know what
matzah is i don't
but my grandmother made carlos beef soup
with uh cucumber with uh
cucumbers and cabbage in there carrots
about carrots and the the carne and
whatever either oxtails or
or beef shanks
the
especially that i grew up very limited
in my scope of food
but
i went to canters
i've been going for i've been going
forever since the 90s
and um
somebody that i knew was from miami and
they were having matzo ball soup and i'm
like what's that oh it's matzo ball soup
and i'm like
but yeah all right
you know i'm you know do you know what
it is i said oh yeah all right of course
i know where it is i didn't know what it
was
and then
it's like you you say no because you're
just
accustomed to say no you're like oh you
want something no i'm okay you don't
know what it is but you just say no you
don't give yourself the experience
the first time i tried matzo ball soup
was at cantor's and let me tell you man
i'll go to matzo ball soup first when i
don't feel well it's the matzah it's the
way that it's made
it's healing it's it's we call it jewish
penicillin
that's what makes it called chicken soup
you know
that they give them chicken soup what is
is it served cold is it served hot
because i thought it was a cold soup no
no it's hot it's a hot bowl of
mozzarella soup it's basically chicken
broth cooked with lots of vegetables
it's a really long process you boil it
for hours
and then you basically just strain the
chicken broth out and you put this big
matzo ball in it which is like kind of a
mixture between a cracker and a dumpling
yeah it's a it's a big never had it yeah
no
i i've never had it sounds good but but
i tell you what now now it's not gonna
be good
you don't have to be sick to eat it
that's that's another thing like i've
never been sick when i hate it but i
mean it's so it's so good and that's
what i think you know when
uh next bite we came to do the tacos and
all of a sudden you know trying to find
a name and then you're trying to find
the place and then you know listen if
your name is cantor like for me i'm a
person of l.a you are i mean you're all
right with me like yeah you know dynasty
it's a strong place it's a forever uh
well-known place around here and as i
said they were just big on the news it
was very very nice piece they did on
them because of bringing their employees
back and the way they treated their
customers and especially
the family atmosphere people were so
happy to be back to work
which is something we're not seeing
today people are reluctant to go back to
work because they're getting
uh
workman's comp or whatever they get you
know they're
yeah it's not working it's a
really challenging time for restaurants
it is right everyone uh would rather be
you know safely at home with their
family and
it is it's been really hard to to
recruit and get people back into the
restaurants to work because
um it you know they are making they're
still high unemployment benefits and and
all that but
but if you think about it like um
you know the restaurant industry
actually employs close to 30 million
people i mean it's a huge chunk of of
america one-third one-third of americans
have worked in a restaurant so this is a
huge industry that we're that we're
supporting and serving
and it's it's it's not just a place of
food it's like these community hubs
that uh that are really these like it's
what creates the neighborhoods that that
are all across
the country so sometimes when you when
people get older like me
and
you know
maybe you don't have as many friends you
know you live they pass and you can go
to a place that makes you feel like
you're surrounded by people who care
about you because they do that you don't
you're not alone when you go to some
place like a deli cantors you go in
there and you see people and you have
conversations with them but
at subway nobody hanging around the
subway
that feeling you get when you go into a
restaurant that's true because
it's getting you out of there
it's just as good if not better than the
food right i mean because it makes you
feel like family makes you feel like
you're wanted you're needed you're
you're here we're happy
and who doesn't want that
well maybe it would help to so we jumped
right into things as we should but maybe
it would help to take a step back and
sort of the explain like i'm five for
the audience version of like so this is
like the whole enterprise george lopez
tacos right
that is a digital kitchen is that the
term uh so it's it george lopez tacos is
a virtual restaurant first of all it's
close mercury style new style of
restaurant it's it's not something that
existed five or ten years ago
um it's basically a restaurant that only
exists online so if you if you have
ubereats or doordash or any of these
apps on your phone you'll open it up and
you'll see all of a sudden there's this
new brand called george lopez tacos
they're we're eating live and they are
delicious i don't know what the
different types are but i've had two so
far
it's got to be you know
if the food is not delicious then what's
the point right you know you know what's
um
what's when you eat it
oh yeah it's not just tacos we got
churros we got some there's all right
there's some chocolate sauce right there
watch out yeah if you're if you're just
listening to the audio you're missing
amazing a feast for the eyes as well
but now
when you would
i'll buckle your pants after you eat
you're like oh
you know this stuff is so good now that
you you don't need to do that and still
be you're not full
but you've had a
a wonderful dining experience i mean you
don't
if i'm if i'm at home i'm gonna buckle
my pants up to start with
well the thing about delivery is um
when we're building brands with delivery
first like with the delivery first
mindset we have an opportunity to to
create from scratch something that we
know is going to work well
in an arrival experience like we'll
literally put food in the car drive it
around for 20 30 minutes and test it to
make sure we get we got the packaging
right that we got you know all the
little details were correct and with
this brand what i love about it is that
it's an experiential taco concept it's
it's a build-your-own brand so it comes
with the pile of meat the stack of
tortillas right all the salsas the
onions the cilantro it's all on the side
and instead of sending the customers
soggy tacos that you know by the time
they arrive the tortilla is breaking and
everything right we've really been
thoughtful about you know how how do we
set this up for success and create a new
experience with tacos this is this is
mind-blowing to me because the realities
are i've seen your advertisement for the
backwards but there's no place near me i
want a restaurant so i said i'm not
going to pay doordash
to come from the ocean come from the
beach right over to my house right
well the deli i know yeah so so the
delivery radius
um the way it works on these platforms
is when we partner with restaurants to
turn them on and have them make the food
for this brand
typically they're serving you know about
three to four miles of
distance across that community in that
area so right now we're partnering with
restaurants all across the country um to
cover all these little three to four
mile delivery radiuses and uh
you know overnight we were able to
launch with over 100 locations which has
never really been done before in the
restaurant industry you can't just
create a brand and launch overnight with
brick and mortar restaurants but with
virtual restaurants and when you're
partnering with restaurant with the you
know these underutilized kitchens to
make the food for this concept it allows
us to move faster than anyone else so
when you so when you say like virtual
you think it's it's fast but it's not
fast because
the experimenting and the getting the
right product has gone it goes on for a
while alex yeah we we have this test
kitchen that we that we rent and we
we actually do a lot of experimentation
we look at a lot of data to know what's
selling well in which markets at what
time of day and we're looking at these
trends that are happening both in the us
and internationally
people's dietary habits and and we're
we're using all that data to design from
scratch these concepts and these menus
that we know are going to to crush it on
delivery and then we launch it in our
test kitchen on these platforms under
multiple names and under multiple logos
we have great photos that we're using
and um and until we dial it in and nail
it and the reviews are coming in and
they're great right once we nail that
whole process down then we scale it and
partner with all these restaurants to
turn it on so we really kind of knock
out all that there's two things there's
two listen you don't you don't have to
like me this is the this is really the
best compliment
people don't like me
even my own people
uh
can i read you no
i wasn't planning
this is your show can i read you
something that someone wrote to me
and i read it last night and yeah i
thought if only if it would be
therapeutic for you i didn't know yeah
don't do it for us do it for you
but
you know when you're working oh we're
going to read it are you careful
are you carrying every latino person on
your back or are you just trying to be a
success for yourself and your family
do i do i
when you went to vietnam did you go for
me or did you go for because you got
drafted you went i joined i didn't get
drafted
so
exactly
all of a sudden
we have to be the
bearer of your the whole culture
i didn't do i didn't have a bigger
struggle
to impress anybody
i struggled because that that's what i
needed to do to get to where i we owe
nobody
nothing
anything double negative nothing nobody
nothing yeah anything i just read an
article by andy rooney rest in peace the
greatest the greatest guy and he
addresses just that we don't owe you
anything you know this it was a great
piece people like him can't talk
publicly anymore you know we all yeah
offending people but it was a great
piece saying exactly the same thing
you're just saying
so
my politics visit from the secret
service whatever
but when it comes to the food
it's it's like they've
removed
what they think of me
and just like the food and that's really
i think one of the best compliments of
any of it all right that's all i have
you see one of these look at this
tabernacle i like the food if you see
one of these jalapenos that's grilled
that camera right there estilo latino
mexicano that's right this isn't just
something that they put in there as
garnish
that looks good it's the best you took a
bite
yeah look at that
you gotta like roast that over actual
fire you gotta roast it i can't mess
around on that that's not a microwave
pepper and
most people have never seen this
or seen one like this uh but
when you order the george lopez you're
going to get
something that you'll see for the first
time you're going to get new clientele
because of the
former adage has always been
the tougher the barrio the better the
thought there you go you know you always
thought now you're going to be able to
get that good taco without having to go
into the batter to get them you can get
a taco that's just as good from a
restaurant that has bars on the window
that's how you would tell them
the taglines are writing you don't have
to have bars on the windows to know that
this is this isn't real and people and
people love it man you know some a
friend of mine african-american his
daughter's probably 14 and said let's
let's have george lopez tacos for
for dinner and they did it they showed
me send me pictures of them put them
together put them together as a family
that's beautiful and and you know we
have 15 brands that we've brought to
life like different types of concepts
from grilled cheese sandwiches to to
your tacos and out of all 15 brands
right now the number one rated brand
across the entire board is george lopez
taco so right
people are loving the food they love the
experience they love the the build your
own kit style it's kind of a new thing
for people and so you sort of have to
like if you're a restaurant you have to
more or less like pass a test you have
to prove you can make this sort of food
but in general any kitchen with like the
bandwidth to
make this stuff as well can also become
sort of like a virtual storefront for
george lopez tacos there are a million
restaurants in the u.s and we believe
over 90 of them have excess capacity in
their kitchen to handle more volume
and we're what we're doing is we're
identifying you know which which areas
we think this might do well in zip codes
all that stuff looking at all this data
and and going and finding a restaurant
in all these different cities and areas
partnering with them and saying if you
carry these ingredients and you make the
food this way right we will turn on this
brand for you on all these delivery
platforms we'll provide you this
technology in your kitchen that will
just print out the orders and all you
have to do is put your head down and
make food and we'll pay you
to do this for us and so we're giving
any restaurant that has the right
kitchen equipment and in the right area
the opportunity to to really light light
up light up their kitchen with more this
is what it's like to explain to you
because you're all your old latino
it's like if you had a tow truck company
but then the police department or the
sheriff's department called you when
they needed to get a car towed and you
win that's just
just on that's good on top of good the
business is already good and then you
get another truck and then you get
another one and all of a sudden you're
not relying on other just normal people
to break down you have law enforcement
calling you and saying can you go pick
up this this truck yeah and that's the
way it works
you know we have we have these
restaurants all across america now some
of them are american food some of them
are
chinese food i mean it doesn't matter
what they're doing
we are able to go in and train them and
say you know this is how you prepare
this food this is what the ingredients
you need to purchase these are the
jalapenos you know everything and uh and
then they can turn on the second concept
using their fixed costs that they're
already using to run their restaurant so
the lights are already on the rent is
fixed the the staff is in the kitchen
whether they bought all the machines
whether whether you're doing one brand
or or a couple brands out of your
restaurant so we're we're really on
we've unlocked this opportunity to
supercharge and the way that
if you get a bad taco they're going to
rat you out
yelp
like a tattletale yeah
so yelp is the mitotic getting involved
and talking trash
they're not going to hesitate to say
i ordered this it wasn't what i expected
and
when it's good
they'll tell you
but also when they're not happy
well that's you know that's one of the
hardest parts about the restaurant
industries people are so critical and
something might happen
like a delivery driver might show up
late
and the restaurant gets blamed every
time because
you know
the the customer who's placing the order
they don't know all the logistics of how
it works so
unfortunately even the best restaurants
in the world if you go on their yelp
page you're gonna see one-star reviews
saying you know this place was
disappointing it was overpriced the food
was cold there's always going to be
misses that happen it's not even always
the restaurant's fault but no matter
what there's going to be haters and
everything that you do so with with this
concept we're trying to just you know
you can't please everyone like you said
okay see how nice he says that you're
gonna be haters and whatever you do but
with this concept we're gonna be able to
come through well if i'd have been a
cantor i bet i'd have been smarter than
i am today
i think you have the same body but i
think you'll be smarter
so growing up there was uh this thing
called you remember chicken delight oh
yeah yes i remember the song
know something tonight called chicken
delights don't cook tonight don't cook
them chicken
so chicken delight
when you would order it it was really
the first
delivery that i ever had in my life
and they put a bucket of chicken on top
of the car so that way you didn't get
excited when every car went down the
street they would just know like that's
not it and then it had a little spring
so when it stopped the bucket was on the
springs it would go like that
i don't know i never got we never got to
order that [ __ ] in my house when you saw
it come around the corner you're like
it's here and then they had like we have
the churros that are that size i wanted
to make them smaller
but they had the like the mojo potatoes
that were the wedges then
and i mean come on so
that so when i started to open the you
know the qingons and all this stuff and
this lady was doing like restaurant
magazines and she says to me uh
one more question
to ask you my editor wanted me to ask
you like why you put your face
as the logo of the restaurant like drive
down the freeway you see your face with
a can
how's my face oh yes and a thing right
so it wouldn't allow me to put my nine
guys up there
whether i'm you know
whatever i am it's just my you know they
wanted me to ask you that and then you
know i said did anybody ask colonel
sanders why he put his face on every
bucket of chicken and the lady was like
okay
[Laughter]
well you know delivery used to
before five ten years ago before all
these apps
the big delivery restaurants were
basically just pizza and chinese food
that's kind of what was known as like
food order for delivery
and and um
oh okay oh good we've got another order
put your apron yeah the orders are going
to be hard
it's going crazy um and and so you know
pizza and chinese is where delivery
started
and then now with these big uh companies
like ubereats and doordash they have
millions of drivers on the road on every
block and and they're going one by one
to these restaurants signing them up for
the for the platform and every
restaurant from fine dining to sit down
family restaurants you know even
michelin star
fancy restaurants in new york are doing
have figured out how to incorporate what
they're doing on their menu for delivery
which is a totally new thing you never
used to be able to order sushi on
delivery and now now it's like every
sushi restaurant and across los angeles
is doing
bento boxes or you know some sort of
version of a menu that works online and
it's all possible because these
companies are doing the delivery for you
as a restaurant it's very expensive for
uh when you're a restaurant it's
expensive to hire your own drivers right
there's insurance there's slow times of
the day where the driver's not doing
anything
but with these companies it really
unlocks the opportunity for any
restaurant to participate and get online
and and reach customers who live within
that so so what it does is it doesn't
leave anybody isolated like you know
it's all kind of like reaching out one
hand washes the other or one thing can
keep someone else in business and keep
other other people in business and isn't
that what business is just relationships
so if i'm if i'm a listener of this
podcast and i am but if i'm a listener
of this podcast like how would i go to
check if there's a george lopez tacos
near me if i'm able to order it what's
the
let me just give you myself all right
take one eight
yeah just text george
no uh there's you know first of all if
you if you have doordash or ubereats or
any of these platforms on your on your
phone uh you simply open up the app and
search and if it's available you can you
can place an order and have it brought
to you otherwise uh you can go to george
lopez tacos.com
and put in your zip code and it will
tell you if there's any locations in
your area and if there's not you can
actually request
that it notifies you when when they do
open up in your area so we're constantly
adding more locations every day i think
today we already signed up two more
locations across ones in florida once in
texas and every day we're turning on
more locations so
so i'm gonna
one you just opened a restaurant in
florida this morning okay so how about
that wherever i this is what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna be in las vegas
labor day weekend
now if you call what's the number of the
podcast 818-533-1843
if you call that number the saturday
of labor day i don't know what day that
is september 6th maybe
there's a calendar app let me check
the first
then which day do you say the the
saturday before labor day saturday
weekend fourth in las vegas september
from 2 p.m to 4 p.m
if you order george lopez tacos
george lopez will deliver them to your
house
wait a minute that's me
i'm going to do this returning hospital
george lopez tacos never mind
from two to four on that saturday what
day is that the fourth september
saturday september 4th
and just order
and i'll let alex know and then i'll be
gonna have are you gonna have a bucket
on on the top of your car
i am i'm gonna put
put some [ __ ]
huh
a little what should i put a little
piggy bank or something mexican picnic
maybe a rock yeah maybe a little bubble
put a bobble head up there you'll know
it's your own head yeah you got to get
your face out you might have to do one
of these cans so that you love putting
your face on there i know i i don't love
it but
i'm skinnier when they draw me so the uh
the so
this will air next week
the day what day is that the 30th and
then uh that weekend i'll go and deliver
you heard you heard the man you heard it
here first all right let's i think
there's no better way to find out what
people want than to go deliver it myself
i may go to vegas just to have you
delivered let's go
there you go come from george and gill
that that would be a i'll be out there
for two hours from two to four
all right baby all right well unless
that's good right let's go
they were
you get my vote awesome well i don't
have to be mindful of time a little bit
today so thank you so much alex for
stopping by thank you alex uh george
lopez tacos anywhere you get delivery
right yeah see if it's in your area
we're in most major cities now and uh
again every day we're signing up new
locations so if we're not in your area
right now we will be at some point so
alex i'd love to meet you formally but
deal career it's a pleasure meeting you
i thank your family for their
humanity the way they are their
graciousness they're just thank you a
wonderful uh wonderful family thank you
so much
yeah exactly i mean it's such a great
place to see and
like i said the movie be cool they
filmed it in there that's right and i'm
gonna go and i'm gonna go try some
monster soup lots please please there's
a bowl with your name on it yeah thank
you alex all right right on awesome
thanks man
[Music]
the world is racing to get back around
and start meeting up in person again but
after the year we've all had getting
back to feeling normal takes time well
you know when you ask somebody who's a
friend and not a licensed therapist like
what would they do or do you think i'm
right or do you think i'm wrong you know
don't put your friends or your family
member in the position that a medical
physician should have get good help uh
fast and get it
quick and that's what talkspace is doing
so you know we all feel overwhelmed
you're not alone
and you can get real support from a
licensed therapist that's what talkspace
is all about whether you're a parent
student millennial or just someone
having a hard day talkspace can provide
the support to
help you feel better
with a single message okay anxiety is
something that shows up in different
ways shows up in shortness of breath
shows up in panic attacks shows up at
the most unexpected times and you don't
know what the trigger could be you know
talk space therapists
um
what they do is they help you develop
tools that
allow you to cope with your emotions in
difficult times gil talkspace also works
around your schedule at your convenience
send and receive unlimited messages with
your dedicated therapist in the app
schedule the live video sessions with
your license therapist from anywhere
whether you're experiencing depression
anxiety or other problems talkspace is
the number one online therapy platform
to help you sort through any so all of
these people are licensed therapists and
they're available to match you with
somebody that you feel comfortable with
so you would get somebody that and you
can you know go through what you like
and don't like you can be honest and
then they'll line you up with somebody
that is always there for you and um
you don't have to feel embarrassed or
make yourself feel um
uncomfortable telling friends or family
because then they'll get in the car and
go
i don't know what's going on with that
dude but
talk space
gives you a place to be honest very few
places like that anymore well there you
go don't hesitate start feeling better
with a single message
match with a licensed therapist when you
can go to talkspace.com and get 100 off
your first month with promo
code omg hi yeah that's 100 off when you
use the code omghi
talkspace.com
so here we are we're going to go back to
when the
netflix released a documentary
night stalker search for a serial killer
hunt for a serial killer
the documentary went out it was a
four-part series and
part of that series it taught well the
series was about the investigators and
the investigation went on
and on my part since i was one of the
investigators it talked about my
relationship with my dad
and my father
all i ever wanted to do was uh
make him proud
i wanted him to be proud of his son
and so
it ended up
in the long run
but it just wasn't about him being proud
of you
at that particular time
it's about being proud of you
your whole life and his whole life yeah
my whole life you know we didn't have uh
we had a loving relationship but we
didn't talk much there wasn't much
communication that went on between us
and i knew he loved me
but uh i i just wanted
to impress him and
unfortunately for me passed away before
the case was adjudicated
and i remember going home and crying
that night and my wife i had never
talked with her i'd never cried as a
bill
and she just reached over and said it's
okay he was with you it was a very
touching time very special
well
after the documentary daniel parks
reached out to me
and when he reached out he said that
he enjoyed the documentary
but that it also touched his heart the
relationship that came across about my
dad
and himself
and his dad and himself
and he was asking me if he had my
permission to do a painting of my father
and i said
you have my permission just let me know
how much it costs when it's done
and i'm there it's my dad it was very
important to me
so he advised me at that time he wanted
to pay it forward he thought that i had
done
uh something nice in the armed forces
and i had done good as a cop and
so it it he wanted it was his time to
pay it forward very special so
i said yes do it
not knowing what to expect what it was
going to be like i didn't know the man
i believe he's from tennessee
and yeah
and i hope the floods haven't gotten you
i pray that everything's safe where
you're at
and it's been right but i mean it's it's
just hot today everything's fine it's
the most bipolar state in terms of
weather come here
so
he sets out and he starts painting and
he took the pictures right from pictures
that they used in the documentary
and i take it the first time i got to
see any but it was about 60 70 done
and he said he wanted to see my reaction
so there was face time going on
and when it was going to happen i had my
wife and my daughter who is now
49 years old standing right behind me
and then he said here it goes and he
showed it to us
i immediately started crying
took my uh
it was seeing my dad
and it wasn't complete yet my wife just
started crying
immediately my daughter said
oh my god that's grandpa
and she had to leave the room she was
crying
that's how much it impacted me
so
i asked
my good friend
george lopez
if he could add me on at least one more
time because i wanted to show the world
the artwork that you had done
we got the artwork in
a little over a month ago
we sent it down to
george lopez recommendation uh a frame
shop here in l.a
and uh
it's mike's monster frames yeah monster
frame monster frame in los angeles what
a job he did it just i picked it up on
saturday it took my breath away i cried
uh my family my sisters haven't seen it
yet
and so i asked george i wanted one more
time here
so i could bring daniel the artist
on the show
to show his work show what he had done
and how it affected myself and my family
and i am eternally indebted
to you sir
and i hope
i just hope
that and i remember one time before you
said it when he showed it to me the
first time he said you were thinking
about giving a painting
but yeah
this had just
renewed your
your belief that you still
had the ability
and i'm here to tell you brother you do
have the ability it's it's remarkable
and i can't thank you enough and now
the world has the ability to see what
you did
for myself and my family
well i appreciate all of you for the
opportunity to be able to show it and
yeah i was about to give it up uh i
when i did this for you it kind of
reminded me the joy that i got out of
showing people what i could do
um before doing it doing this for you
about a year ago i ran
that's where i was telling my art and it
got to the point where i was getting too
busy to keep up by myself so i had to
discontinue that for a while and a few
months in i didn't draw it on i just
kind of lost it and saw the documentary
and i was like you know i can really
tell that he
loves his dad and i can't say the same
thing for myself i'm like i admire that
kind of relationship and one of my
dreams is to be a dad so when i see your
dad you know had that effect on you
i admire that i and i envy that
but for you
again
so i i had a blast doing it i think this
is the best time i've ever had doing a
project um
i mean hell
i i've done like probably a hundred
projects for like special people in my
life and this is definitely by far blows
it out of the water my favorite
i i enjoyed it even the second one that
i did for you was even you know what i
what i think just just
what i think is great about
just art and
you know
what people connect to you know
i mean it brought us together and
brought uh daniel together
but i got the same
reaction
that daniel got watching it let us can
we show the picture do you mind yeah
yeah i appreciate it aaron if you can
cut to uh i'll hold it up in the middle
um hold it yeah hold it up
is that um
you know if you say to somebody hey
don't be a stranger and that's somebody
you know but don't be a stranger in the
ability to connect to something and
connect to someone i mean
um
it's a beautiful picture you want yo
describe describe what daniel uh did
daniel what he did was he took two
pictures
and he blended and he painted it in one
one is a picture of my dad by himself he
took from
standing just a picture he just
eliminated any of the background or
anything else behind him
and he showed him holding an 8x10
picture standing next to me
uh the day
the day i graduated from the academy for
the sheriff's academy
and holding it close to his heart
and
even captured my dad's missing fingers
man
so it was uh
and it looks
just like my dad i just
uh
it's beautiful
so many
uh
so many memories and he he passed
uh it was funny because before he worked
uh
people just say hey mexican come over
here and he'd laugh jokingly saying
i'm not mexican and he'd point down to
his arms and he'd say i'm just i'm
smoked irish just a little well done
and
he died
on st patrick's day 42 years ago
so
he took him on st patrick's day the
irishman that he was and you brought him
back to life
and he'll hang proudly in my house where
i'll be able to see him
and my grandkids my my kids are just
uh so overwhelmed
my grandkids that
never knew my dad but they've seen
pictures and heard me talk about them
they just couldn't believe how well it
was done so like i said
i'm forever indebted and this will be
something that will stay with me for the
rest of my life
well thank you so much man i mean
honestly the fact that it resonates with
you that much um because i was being
hard on myself the whole time like i was
like you know asking the family like hey
does this look like him does this look
like him and then i think my mother was
like uh she was like uh what's up burt
reynolds doing on on the on
that's like that's not real
not the program come on
uh
some uh just the opportunity i mean
george
cool to see you i mean
and i met you as mr electric when i was
like two
uh so
good to meet you uh and gail again man
like to me in my heart you're a hero
because
you know the documentary kind of touches
how you were you know also a war hero
and and
uh and they kind of capitalized how you
kind of
were
kind of treated like crap your idea and
your theory so i like the fact that
you're getting all of this
positive energy back into your life for
that you know and i hope that
like you had we talked on the phone
earlier you said that uh you had made a
new friend out of a woman that has a
joke and you know connections like that
is what it's all about so i'm glad i was
able to bring you that experience to you
and this is what the coolest things i've
done
well i'm i'm extremely happy and i'm
glad that we met and i can't thank you
enough
i don't know what you're doing for
business now but
is there any way if somebody else wanted
to get in touch with you for money
how do they are you still interested how
would they get in touch with you
if they wanted you to do some business
they can get in touch with me through
facebook
all right um
same name through facebook and they can
just contact me through there i used to
have a social media but i just kind of
went off of it for a while
um i haven't really ignited it to back
up because when i posted the my artwork
like i remember at one point um got like
close to 100 000 likes at one point
and it kind of intimidated me and i
didn't know how because i only have two
hands you know i can't you know
draw 30 000 shoes at once so
yeah
um i have a piece of artwork i'm going
to show you guys just one sec yeah
also when you when you get back if you
can still hear me uh let's grab whatever
the name of your facebook is just like
spell it out so people can you know
leave no guesswork if they want to find
you
d-a-n-i-e-l
and then parks as in p-a-r-k-s like
parks and recreation there you go daniel
parks on facebook uh to enlist his
services my goofy mug has the cover i
don't know how many daniel parks there
is in the world but there can't be that
many um and if you're looking for a
testimonial
skills the best this his intro was maybe
one of the best things i've ever heard
so yeah
oh that's awesome oh great so uh what
describe for for the audience what
you're holding up right now uh so this
um was a popular subject that i drew
this is an uh
a rap artist that passed away a few
years ago um by the name of little peep
and i had a large of his fan base asked
me to draw this [ __ ] and this was just
an example of what i did i probably drew
stuff like this like 70 times
this is
for money for a while but yeah i'm open
to transmissions
jackets
pants canvases
shoes
um
i've done walls before too that's uh
yeah those vans look
these look pretty amazing man that's
well done dude
you can go in the picture on one yeah
put one with cheech and one with cheong
on one
there you go
i've had that i did one with snoop on it
not too long ago
um
and george you were actually a
commission idea that never went through
they wanted uh your face on the shoe
uh
you know with your catchphrase from the
nickelodeon show on the side of the
other shoe yeah so i thought that was a
cool idea too
all of it works man that's awesome all
right daniel i'm sure we'll see you
again dude
all right man thank y'all for having me
on yeah daniel thank you
thank you gil all right man y'all take
it easy save stuff check him out
there you go daniel parks on facebook
and if anyone if we if we get word that
anyone reaches out to him and tries to
get someone oh for free or for exposure
or something like that let's put him on
blast that's right that's a man who
deserves to be paid for his efforts
um
i gotta say one of my favorite parts
about being on this podcast when i
do get beyond is like is is seeing
people like like you gail and george and
daniel for that matter like just having
moments like that like being being
vulnerable like you could hear the
emotion in your voice as as you were
describing this thing and like
i don't know that's something that i
find very cool and inspiring as well is
like you're someone who on the outside a
lot of people would think like oh just
sort of you know gruff cool dude but
you're you know you were more than happy
it seems to be like hey this had me you
know this had me feeling emotional i'm
not afraid to dig back into that right
now i know something that i just think
is very cool
to see because there's not a lot of role
models in there i'm secure in my manhood
hey it happens i can't deal with it
what's going on with you um
personally in your life like you have
the vfw go over there and you see those
guys see the guys and then you travel
you've traveled a little bit right this
year with the pandemic and now it's just
uh i look forward to mondays doing the
podcast with you i go down to bfw on
tuesdays uh last two last week we did
the podcast on tuesday so i went
straight from here to the vfw
i took their picture sent it to you i'm
dying to see them tomorrow night because
you put in there in my regards to the
bottles from the bfw yeah they'll laugh
it's all good i'll be leaving uh
on the 8th of september i'm going to
dallas to do a speaking engagement
coming back
uh
if we secure the 11th
for the fights
we're down okay because
i can uh they wanted me to stay and come
back on saturday morning
which puts me here at 11 o'clock which
is fine but i just don't trust the air
with the weather and stuff like that so
i may come back on friday if i can get
out on friday i'll come back on friday
instead
because i definitely want to go to the
fights awesome and and what what fight
is that for our for our fans for the
listeners
it is
versus
his demons
now that that's a [ __ ] good one right
now
who gets the pay-per-view chunk yeah uh
yeah and he's fighting the mma fighting
eminem yeah i'm double checking uh vitor
bell firms yeah right which was an mma
is that right yeah
and you know i was at oscar's fight
against pacquiao which which didn't go
well but
you know
what's in the heart of i mean listen man
i mean
you know staying too long in the game is
what fighters
do i mean muhammad ali
was stopped
on the stool like you don't want to do
that
but
you know oscar told me when he was
preparing for pacquiao it's like
when you know you're toward the end of
your career and you know
if you win you know you should get out
but you think you got one more in you
and if you lose you think you should get
out but you don't want to go out on a
loss and that push-pull that's what
drags you you have to live with for the
rest of your life so for him to do this
it's maybe over it's got to be over 10
years from the last time i think it's
something like 13 years since his last
sanction fight or official fight or
something like that yeah i'll be glad to
be there to cheer him on watch it just
to go in there and
put gloves on after that amount of time
and to challenge yourself i don't know
what you expect it to be i mean it's not
going to be like he was in his prime but
he has ability and he's
working really hard it's not a team
sport either you're going there you put
it all on the line and
he's a true warrior for doing it it
really it really is uh
when he was doing media day for
pacquiao i went up to big bear
and sparred with him for
no kidding 30 seconds it took me a day
and a half to catch my [ __ ] breath
well just a high altitude we're used to
and my legs i don't know those guys man
and then
you're getting hit while you're trying
to work
you know that's yeah that's what's crazy
like doing my homework when i was with
my grandmother
uh
but
anybody who has the balls to step on the
stage of whatever
uh size or whatever
sport or whatever craft
gets
respect from me because there's a lot of
people there's millions of people
who
talk themselves out of things that scare
them or things that intimidate them or
things that
they're not sure they would be good at
well when you start you're not good at
it but that doesn't mean that you can't
stick with it and potentially be
be good at it and if everybody
thought that i think most of the
athletes that i admire or celebrities
that you admire come from not humble
beginnings but turbulent beginning
student where
you know not everything was
what a child would want or a family
would want but
those are the things that draw you to
want to be
um
applauded or
laughed at when you go there you know
it's something for you yeah but then
sometimes you know
it look at macho camacho i mean i
i i was watching this showtime
documentary i'd love to get his mom
on this show you know he
he struggled with drugs and his own
demons and
you know when he still thought he could
fight there's a there's a
scene toward the end of his documentary
on showtime where
they go and try to wake him up to go
to go and run
because they got him a fight and he says
listen man i appreciate you guys
for trying to help me but i'm a junkie
man all i want to do is get high
and [ __ ] that's
wow that's the
it wasn't the bottom because he got shot
waiting in a car somewhere in a bad
neighborhood but
it's it's just one of the most honest
things i've ever seen in on video and
ramos uh was a fighter that didn't want
to fight he was afraid to get in the
ring and he kept fighting for his dad
you know his dad was pushing him and he
didn't like getting in the ring
and i've seen him fight i see him well
up until before the pandemic i'd still
see him around
around the fight game with stuff
tough business man stuff
mma and all that stuff too
is that's almost a bare knuckle man it's
not like the little jack johnson [ __ ]
that bare knuckle
stuff right because
yeah and they barely got any pads on the
there's barely
i think allegedly that's better at the
end of the day at least like bare
knuckle is technically better because
then like
the thing that gets in the way is you
hurting your hand so like if you have
really good gloves you can throw a punch
to mess someone up and with if you
didn't have gloves you wouldn't throw
that punch because you're hurting
yourself too
so i have heard some people even argue
that like oh knuckle i'm safer in some
way i don't know i i deplore violence
i was at the fight uh at staples when
what was the guy's name that had the
that had the
cement wraps on his hands uh oh yeah
yeah yeah the mexican
uh mexican guy dirtiest fighter in the
car and he
[ __ ] could have killed somebody kind
of killed the one guy like really just
brutalized him and then
the athletic commissioner comes over to
me because we were waiting and he's like
oh man
i just came from the dressing room and
they took they made the guy take his
gloves off and he put like quick
was this margarito margarita plaster of
paris
paris it's like what paper mache stuff
is made out of plastic pair is what cats
are made out of
so that was this thing where
they would wrap his hands and he
wouldn't
necessarily show people but he's
wrapping them and then wetting them and
you're fighting with two cement blocks
on your hands
not good not good so
good luck oscar he'll be on the podcast
um
next week in the lair
right after that it'll arrive when the
run around the time the week of his uh
the week of his flight that's good and
what's what's the little
update that you have for us well i i
the
the lady that called in and said wanted
to know of the fact that she had been
happily married for years and
things were going well and she loved her
husband but twice a year she felt like
she needed to cheat on him
and these urges were getting to her and
she asked the question does that make me
a big puta
well after we got done laughing we
answered the question seriously and said
you know to each his own if that's what
you want if it keeps your marriage
together whatever you want to do it's
not our business
well she reached out to me on instagram
and let me know that she was happy she
didn't think that we'd air it but we did
and she laughed
she looks at
you and myself as her two teals
and everything is good
she then continued the fact that she
told her husband
what she had done
and
he was not happy but everything was
still working out they were talking
about it they were discussing it
so she told her husband that she was
like hey i left a voicemail for this
show and i said i i love you i would
never cheat on you but yeah once a year
i want to yes and then that first
message sent me i said by the way i've
been married 12 years and i've never
cheated on my husband
so this was just something she had
inside her she felt like it
well after explaining it to him after
this thing aired she says he got pissed
off and he didn't like it he was upset
with her but after they talked about it
he was
things were cool
so i reached out to her
this time i reached out i said hey
you know do you mind if we talk give an
update to the listening audience or the
viewers
because your story was not only yes it
was funny
but yet it was cool and interesting you
know since you've gone along it's very
interesting to me because
we're so
we're kind of all raised to a
you know this kind of
the way that even vows are written till
death do us part forsaken all others and
and it's definitely a different
mindset that comes from some
sure i mean i'm not and then depending
on where you're from i mean my wife's
from the bottom
i was just at the concert saturday night
and there was a lady sitting next to me
that was loaded
and my wife was watching her and and she
looked like she was with
you know uh
mr goodbar you know it was sugar daddy
right and she was loaded and every time
he wasn't looking around if i looked to
my left and i had some friends friends
of mine sitting on the other side of her
uh
videl
videl from the 180. oh yeah yeah he was
sitting down he'd come and said hello
and we hugged
sitting a couple seats down
and i'd look to my left and every time i
looked at my left she'd look at me and
she was winking and one time she started
lifting up her dress and i looked at
what i had to turn back around and i
told the wife i said she's either gonna
pull down her calzones or she's showing
me that she doesn't have any calzones on
and so it was very very unsanitary
very unsanitary and i was worried i was
worried about covet you know so it was
unsanitary
and so but my wife kept my wife kept an
eagle eye on her she's from nevada so
for something like this for this lady to
call and say i have these feelings you
know
yeah and and so
some people
aren't open-minded some people don't
have the understanding
and hey if it doesn't hurt me i don't
care what anybody does you know sex is
whatever makes you feel good
so i
wrote back to her and i said hey do you
mind if we talk about it on the show as
a follow-up because
i want to know you know listeners want
to know whatever happened
to the lady
and so she says yeah go ahead just you
told me you're not going to mention her
so i'm not mentioning her name
but
her and her husband have been talking
they're both happy he's aware of her
feelings
and so they're moving forward now and
hopefully she'll give me an update uh if
anything occurs if she welds her dreams
or fantasies whatever they are well you
know how about to the people that are
listening and people that have uh
been involved i mean there were swingers
clubs you know there was swingers
knights
uh
at some bars there were uh swingers
nights there was uh you know there's a
a bar on roscoe it's not there anymore
but it would say for the over 40 crowd
like that a bar that was
just for people that were over 40
um
you know if you look at um
i mean i think this is
a bit of a of something that is
you know
anybody would be would consider
dangerous tinder
of meeting somebody on tinder if you
look on youtube or you look at
documentaries there's a ton of things
that people meet on craigslist and there
was that doctor that was killing the
killing girls on craigslist
you know he'd invite him over and then
he was he was cutting them up and you
know and those things continue to you
know thrive i don't know what the most
popular dating app is but you know you
swipe and then you meet somebody and
then you go and
i mean it's
incredibly i would say it's incredible
there was a bar nightclub out in the
orange county area because i remember
went to eat dinner with two other
couples
and we're having dinner at this
restaurant they said that's a place
right across the street they're talking
about place across the street it was a
cocktail lunch
and it was known surprise to me
it was known as being a cougar hangout
you'd go in there young man cougars were
picking up on all the guys over there
and i said god god bless them
so the stuff's out there this lady just
came out and talked about it she joked
about it initially but it sounds like
she's serious and she wants to go
through with it so
more power to her
and
she's going to keep me updated i went to
the bird's nest in uh
rancho mirage's old club that's there
and it's really for old people
and this lady came up to me and asked me
to dance and she was probably in her
late 70s and i said
i said no
and then
she said why not and i said
because i have to go
shave my goatee off if it's going to
make me look like i'm
at the same age range as you are if it
makes you think you gotta take a chance
i went to the bathroom and they had a
guy in there an attendant and i said man
you gotta raise her and he's like i got
one in my car
can you go get it i [ __ ] [ __ ] right
there
[Laughter]
did you go back and dance with her no
yeah
uh
i you know i'm i'm not you know i talked
about not being up but i'm not dating
i'm not dating anybody in the for the
rest of my life i don't know how long
i'm going to live
but done you swore off today i think i
think so is it the last the last time a
few times you're just not done with it
was there a big thing was it just you
feel this way you're
you're at a point where it's like yeah
too much work don't need it
i kind of don't need it yeah
i mean
i don't know how exciting your life is
when you're trying to learn a song that
was written 55 [ __ ] years ago on a
guitar but it makes me happy
yeah that occupies your time hey if that
floats your boat do it brother and i'm
not arguing with anybody i'm not having
anybody say
you know you get to do whatever you want
to watch you can do that the house is
pretty good you know
so i i don't expect
you know
although i might have a date for oscar's
fight though but we'll see
all right i did send you a message
that's gonna be a big night my wife
wants the
she's gonna go yeah i know so so she's
going and then uh
it'll be fun we'll go there and watch
the preliminary fights and
right yeah
get some drinks and
there you go watch the great return it's
a great return of the great oscar de la
hoya that's good
so after september i have uh october
coming up and i'll be going to atlanta
georgia to be a speaker back in atlanta
georgia
and that'll probably be it for
for speaking engagement yeah i got a
couple of the press zoom zoom stuff
between now and then
uh for private companies
but uh that's it spending time around
the house with grandkids
i was uh
i was fortunate
you know i don't know all this stuff
happens liza calls me up yesterday
and invited my wife and myself
to go to uh football game did you go to
the game no i couldn't go we already had
planned the grands kid my daughter and
grandkids were coming down so
liz i'm sorry but we've already got
plans
but just the mere fact that she reached
out to me uh made me feel
wonderful you know yeah nice lady what's
going to happen do you think with
all these sporting events where people
are fighting man like tall i mean really
throwing blows i mean if i took mine
into
a game and that was going on around now
i think it would just you know
put a scar on a kid like you don't want
your kids to see people no throwing and
throwing racial epithets at each other
and
people are afraid and
you know i don't i don't really go to
many sporting events i just go to a ton
of dodger games and i went to a lot of
languages but you know over the pandemic
of course but
you know
at some point
and and this is
what all sporting
venues have to worry about i wish they
would that at some point people are
going to stay home yeah my daughter
called me up a couple years ago angels
were at dodger stadium
and she's there with uh my niece
they went together
and my daughter's an adult i mean she's
gonna be 50 this year
and she calls me up after the game she
goes dad what am i what do i do
there's a great big brawl going right
outside and i just stay inside just wait
wait until security says it's all clear
you know just and she's dramatic anyway
but i said just
be cool just stay clear stay inside
you're you're protected while you're
still inside there
and but this is something that can't
continue to happen yeah this has got to
be stopped somehow
yeah i mean do you think it's it's one
of those things where it's actually
happening at a much greater rate than
before or maybe we're just noticing it
at a greater rate than before because
i've seen it too i've seen more of these
videos i think it's happening more i
think they're
drinking more enjoying it less and when
they're
upset and now they're going to show
their macho then then the fight starts
do you think any amount of that is like
people just getting riled up from a year
and a half of covid quarantine you think
it'll come maybe back down or
no i just i just think it's reckless
drums i mean that's that's all it is
there's there's a macho
and there's i don't think it's being
pimped up you know they're just they're
drunk they're well you have thugs you
know they started to cut beer sales off
after like the seventh inning yeah and
now they might
they're thugs
you know it's going to eventually get if
they can't stop it's going to get like
the airlines stop serving boots
fortunately they still serve in first
class yeah but the coach is gonna cut it
off altogether you know there was a
thing i'm sure everybody saw that they
had to [ __ ] duct tape a [ __ ] dude
into the seat yeah that was nuts but you
know it used to be that if you you
created i mean you're
you're a detective you're in law
enforcement
if you created a disturbance in the air
it was just straight to prison not sure
what the penalty is but
um if you were creating a disturbance in
the air or had too much to drink or were
fighting on a plane that was immediately
like you're gonna do time and just
hundreds of them that we've seen and
just this past week they announced that
the courts are tightening up and they're
not the feds are not messing around with
them they're locking them up
they're not giving them hall passes
they're not letting them go just don't
come to my no they're locking them up
they said it's been
too prevalent it's got to stop it used
to be the one thing that you could rely
on is that if you were even drunk i mean
i've been hammered and flown but you'd
either sleep or anything but you're not
getting into it
actually i did get into it with a dude
on first class one time i said uh
he was talking really loud and i said
hey man you want to shut the [ __ ] up
and that
i'm like listen man you're still [ __ ]
talking loud it's a red-eye flight shut
the [ __ ] up
or i said
or we'll land and then we'll see what
what ore is
but i mean this dude was
he was drunk and he was talking loud and
i was so you know i was gonna people
were looking around nobody want to say
anything yes i'll say something i'll be
the guy
and i was talking a lot one time the
dude told me to be quiet
and
you know what i now see how this feels
from the other side
i haven't thought of punch
since i adopted three dogs ago no
wow
i can't i could never fight i can't
remember the last time i got it i can't
run or fight i just
i think i just [ __ ] on myself when
nobody wants
that nobody
[Laughter]
some sort of defense mechanism he's
[ __ ] himself yeah it's like my
defense mechanism get him oh yeah
one of my nephews asked me one time what
would you do if they came up and they
wouldn't beat you
i said i'd [ __ ] a big turd in my hand
and just hold and say who's first
put on your fist come on i have seen
videos of like like street brawls or
something and you know someone like rip
off their shirt other guy like get naked
and just freaks the other guy out and he
bolts
yeah it's
i do like the straps on youtube yeah
street yeah that was good those are good
ones what do we have what else what else
do we have
are we good uh yeah i mean we had a
great we had two guests this was a nice
little wham bam boom good episode we'll
uh come and we come back next week do
some voice mails with uh with oscar yeah
let's do that all right
awesome well thanks uh thanks to alex
cantor for coming out with uh with next
bite and george lopez tacos right thanks
as well to daniel parks uh a fantastic
artist put together oh great guy you did
a great thing for you that's a beautiful
picture and is gill reading a commercial
right now uh no but uh once we cut we're
gonna do something all right
thank you everybody for listening to oh
my god hi
thank you
bye
you